[Music]
you eat people I know it's just that I'm
so much more confident so fun and so
crazy in the best possible world I know
you know what we need that in the world
right now I also love how candid you've
been about how how tough the last year
was for you and talk about how this show
has helped you kind of like restart and
regain your clout
Sheila my character died basically in
the first episode becomes a zombie the
undead and with that becomes an
awakening for her life and that gave me
one too and I lost like 20 pounds
playing her and like had a whole
attitudinal shift and plucked my
eyebrows and I don't know just started
thinking like a woman again and it was
amazing and I just love her she's she's
someone I I fell in love with along the
way what would Sheila do I would ask
myself probably something inappropriate
but also I think she's got this great
feminist empowerment thing going for her
that was very positive for me and you
know I got a second wrong way but I
gotta ask you about the those scenes
eating human flesh and even though I
know it's fake
oh it'd be like dehydrated apples or
like some stuff that tasted like a jolly
rancher but was like an edible plastic
sometimes it was wet cake
always a different thing
[Music]